but the thing that we can do is we can
organize we can get around our
communities because there's plenty of
people in the community that are sick
and tired of this stuff they're tired of
people telling them what they can and
can't do when you can and can't vote
what you can and can't do with your your
your body um how you can a canned parent
who you can and cannot love and i think
that's where we're getting to where
america is just sick and tired of that
[ __ ]
and there are options
um out there this is one of them uh he's
running around the state of texas
talking in communities and having
community talk hey texas paul i wonder
if anyone will recognize the guy in this
video
i think it's what you tweeted um earlier
but this is i'm telling you folks
democracy is the way out of this this
nonsense it really is the way out that's
why they're fighting so hard against
democracy
is because they know
it's their worst enemy that's why
they're doing it so let's watch this
little tape here uh from the beto
campaign see if you recognize someone uh
in in in through the video are we in the
fight of our lives but we are going to
fight like hell we are going to win this
election on the night of november 8th
we're going to do it for each other
we're going to do it for texas
emily
we just learned that there are hundreds
of others who are outside who could not
get in today
i want to make sure
that they hear us
loud and clear greg abbott has failed
the people of texas and he's killing the
women among us right now i want you to
remember that
but there's an answer to that
for a democrat in denton county in 2016
was 37 percent two years later we won 46
my argument to you
is if you will sign up with us today and
listen
we must win this election i ask you to
take just one
volunteer shift we go out and meet the
voters and when we put this before them
as it was put before the voters in
kansas a referendum on a woman's right
to make her own decisions about her own
body we win this election we restore
those protections we ensure that women
can make their own decisions going
forward are you with me on this
let's do this
this is how you do it paul this is how
you do it this is how you lean into
democracy this is how you engage and i i
could play the last minute or so where
they're signing up people
to do the block walks where they're
walking around talking to people because
that's what i've been telling everyone
you have to talk to your family your
friends the people in your neighborhood
your colleagues your church parishioners
the people at the pta damn the people in
the line at the grocery store because
now is the time to save our democracy
not after we can't wait until steve
bannon the steve bannon types take over
the house we can't wait for his
candidates tim and trump's candidates to
take over the house we have to do this
now now this next two months is so
crucially important that we engage in
our democracy and beto is laying out a
great great strategy for any candidate
out there to go and talk about community
now you were at this event
yeah yeah it was great i'm telling you
folks the the
if you've never been to one of beto's
town halls or
it's just full of energy i mean it is
full of energy everybody there is
excited and motivated um i actually sat
right next to a woman who
leaned over after she figured out who i
was and
you know i kept taking pictures with
people and people you know they
recognized me right away um and i you
know i probably took 50 pictures that
day but it was fun it was a blast she's
she leans over she's like who are you
and i explained and she's like oh well
you're probably not going to like this
but i'm a republican and i'm like no i
love the fact that you're a republican
tell me about it and she has been a
lifelong republican
and
she was there because
roe v wade drove her there
she's like this is not my party i am not
maga i am not these people i am
never trump
and they're just they've this is wreaked
down to the state level so badly
that
i just can't
ignore it and vote republican anymore so
i want to find out what's going on and
she absolutely
loved better
loved betto she realized that you know
there aren't really that many
differences between us i mean when you
start talking about the differences
between the republicans and democrats in
general
it's when you get into the fine details
that is mostly the difference
um
you know it's it it's it's it's you know
they always say devil's in the details
that's where most the difference is is
in the details because if you get the
and i'm not talking about maga i'm
talking about the republicans that joe
biden identified that worked with him to
get his agenda passed
those are the people
that really don't have that much
difference between us
and and
you know
this lady is not a one-off every
one of these rallies you go to
these people are everywhere they're
former republicans they're people that
and she doesn't know it but she's a
democrat now
once she casts that ballot she'll be
okay with the title
right you know right now it's because of
the culture wars she's like well i guess
i have to say i'm an independent
and i'm like well you're welcome we've
got a big tent here right right well
because we're the pro-democracy it's the
pro-democracy side right and and i i
hate that we have to say sides but
really we're at a situation where we
don't have two parties you either are
pro-democracy
or you're for fascism at this point
because they have drawn the line the
fascists have drawn that line in the
sand and beto is not playing into that
right he's not playing into the chaos
machine and the [ __ ]
what i love best is you called it a
rally but every single one of these
videos and you've been to several of
these events paul
when i watch these videos they're in
small
venues they're not in big huge arenas
because i mean as many people as with at
this event he could fill an a big
auditorium he could fill a big venue but
he's not doing that because i think beto
really at the heart of this and this is
what people are seeing
is that it's about
texas it's about community it's about
those people not some scary enemy that
doesn't exist it's about you
your government your democracy is about
you
tell us paul
all these events you've been to is that
what you're seeing
absolutely at at this particular event
in denton
where i'm in the video where you see the
side profile of the you know
they got me when i was was was
enthralled but
when we walked outside
i didn't get a picture with that at this
event
you know normally we'll we'll shoot the
breeze for about two or three minutes
and i'll get a picture and you know
we'll we'll talk for a minute no not
this time
there were literally
more people standing outside
watching on a video screen and listening
to a simulcast then there were people in
the building and we packed that building
to code
they would not the fire marshal would
not allow another soul in that building
they were literally standing room only
all the way to the wall
you know um when we got outside to take
pictures that line was already
more than a football field long
i mean and he stood there and talked
with every one of these people i mean he
must have been there for three or four
hours taking pictures after after two
and two
about two and a half hours uh mrs texa
paul and i gave up and we said hi we're
going home
you